[Music]
[Music]
despite the countless dragon ball games
that have appeared since the manga
debuted in the mid 80s
the series has never needed them to
sustain its popularity most are
forgettable some are good but even fewer
are truly great thanks to developer Arc
System Works particular talents
Dragonball Fighters is one of the great
ones if not the best yet whether still
or in motion fighters art looks like
Dragonball at it's very best
adhering closely to the standards set by
series creator Akira Toriyama and no
matter how you may have watched the show
the option to choose between Japanese
and English voice acting makes it easy
to feel connected to the events on
screen you can't let your guard down
even if you've already won but then the
convincing Dragon Ball shell is a fast
paced 3v3 tag-team fighting game that
will feel familiar to Marvel vs. Capcom
3 veterans but despite a few familiar
parallels fighters is distinctly
Dragonball every character can jet
through the air in a flash at any time
toss energy blasts like it's nothing and
unleash a flurry of small punches and
kicks to stagger a hesitant opponent
these super beings are incredibly
powerful and fighters translates that
energy to the screen perfectly
it also makes it easy for anyone to tap
into that power with relatively short
special attack lists and one button or
two button activations for Universal
mechanics like any great fighting game
fighters doesn't lose depth just because
it's accessible super attacks and
teleports are easy to pull off but they
come with timing and combo conditions
that allow for expert level analysis and
strategic play it's also important to
properly manage the lone meter that
fuels most of your special abilities a
setup that makes fighters next move more
unpredictable than usual compared to
some games with multiple of building
specific meters
[Music]
of course you also don't have to be an
aspiring online competitor to enjoy
fighters as it includes a significant
story mode that can last a dozen hours
or more if you seek out every possible
cutscene while a [ __ ] run out in places
and relatively easy until the conclusion
it's still a treat for Dragon Ball fans
with plenty of new vignettes starring
classic characters Dragon Ball super
characters on the roster notwithstanding
but the plot is split into three arcs
you are technically seeing one arc from
different perspectives with a few
alternate events to keep things
interesting because there's practically
zero time spent introducing you to the
characters or their world it's difficult
to imagine how a newcomer to Dragon Ball
would understand things like the gimme
forces proclivity to pose dramatically
or the reason why Crillon doesn't have a
nose let alone the broad concepts of
Super Saiyans and Dragon Balls then
again
the mix of oddball antics and hyper
serious face offs is inherently
appealing for the confident cartoon
expression on display which requires no
additional context to enjoy as in combat
arcs capable design skills make the 3d
models and environments and cutscenes
looks stunningly close to actual 2d
animation there are moments when you
feel like you're watching a new episode
of Dragon Ball Z but there is a catch
you're forced to press a button to
advance dialogue rather than allowed to
kick back and watch the show when
fighters gets a colon close to
recreating the look of the anime the
forced interaction feels like a step in
the wrong direction albeit a minor one
in the grand scheme of things story
modes real downfalls how repetitive it
becomes you fight clones of only a
portion of the games overall roster ad
nauseam each chapter is presented like a
map locations connected by a branching
path in order to get to the chapter boss
you have to navigate the board and pick
and choose your fights along the way
given that there are optional pathways
in each chapter and that you can concoct
your own team it's not surprising to
learn that there are optional cutscenes
to unlock depending on these conditions
despite the rewards being largely
enjoyable after a handful of hours
fighting lackluster opponents the idea
of replaying story chapters to see a
quirky character interaction is
unfortunately one that's
to sideline similarly the game's basic
small over world feels unnecessary even
though it attempts to add value modes
are divided among spokes around a
circular hub and you can run around as
small versions of the games characters
sometimes an alternate outfits the game
tries to earn your interest throughout
lockable avatars but even if this sounds
good you can only earn them through
randomized loot boxes you earn money as
you fight in complete story mode
milestones and these can be cashed in
for a capsule which turns into a random
cosmetic item there unfortunately no
alternate costumes available for combat
rather than harm the game this system
just feels unnecessary as none of the
rewards are critical to enjoying what
matters most participating in explosive
battles and enjoying interactions
between dragon balls lovably bizarre
characters though merely a small piece
of the overall puzzle the rare dramatic
finishes are perhaps the most
respectable and impressive nod to fans
in fighters anyone who spent years
watching Dragon Ball Z unfold over
nearly 300 episodes will gasp the first
time they trigger one which will only
happen with certain matchups on her
particular conditions they have nothing
to do with fighters story but they have
everything to do with the revered
history of the series at large
[Music]
surely after release been an AAMCO
servers were inundated with eager
players to the point that it was often
difficult to get into a lobby at all
this no longer seems to be an issue
thankfully though even when servers
behave as they should the hub world at
the center of it all proves to make
matchmaking with friends an even more
complicated process than it ought to be
rather than simply inviting a friend
into a match you have to coordinate to
make sure you're both in the same server
and the same Lobby before finding each
other's avatars and creating a private
match lock of the password it doesn't
take long to get used to but it's also
another sign that perhaps the hub world
is an unnecessary complication online
quirks aside fighters is built to
satisfy demanding fighting game
competitors but there's no question that
it's been designed to tap into the
hearts of Dragon Balls most dedicated
fans and no doubt that those same
qualities will win people over who've
never given the series a chance where
past games attempted to get there
through huge rosters and deliberately
predictable trips down memory lane
fighters has bottled the essence of what
makes the series characters animation
and sense of humor so beloved and a
reconfigured it into something new a
Dragon Ball fighting game that can go
toe-to-toe with the best of the job
[Music]